this is a really interesting piece uh in
the new york in the los
angeles times rather by doyle mcmanus
called
joe biden has become the anti-reagan
and his speech to congress will make
that clear now this was of course
written before
last night's speech but it was really
confirmed by the address joe biden gave
to a joint session of congress last
night
joe biden and his biden amics his
economic ideas as they're being called
are truly based on the opposite
principles of reaganomics reaganomics
boiled down was
supply side economics sometimes called
trickle-down
the belief that cutting government
spending is good for the economy cutting
taxes
income taxes and capital gains taxes
particularly on the rich is good for the
economy
reducing regulation on business is good
for the economy tightening the money
supply is good for the economy
and also reaganomics includes the idea
that giving
people help will make them lazy joe
biden
and bidenomics as they've been dubbed
are the
exact opposite of reaganomics now to be
really clear
this doesn't have to mean that biden is
ultra left or is left as bernie or
whatever
but his views are truly the opposite of
reaganomics reaganomics is supply side
economics
joe biden is demand side stimulate the
economy with spending and by increasing
demand reaganomics is about cutting
government spending they almost think
you can cut your way to prosperity
joe biden believes you increase
government spending on the right things
and that's good for the economy it
creates jobs it injects money
into small business reaganomics is
cutting income taxes and capital gains
especially for the rich but biodynamics
is about increasing them on the people
most able to pay
since we know that the hoarding of money
by those people
is not economically stimulative compared
to well thought out properly targeted
government programs
reaganomics wants to reduce regulation
on business and let it rip
let them do whatever the hell they want
joe biden recognizes we must regulate
in order to prevent the further
destruction of our environment which
long term
would be terrible for the world and of
course terrible for the american economy
reaganomics wants to cut the money
supply often they want higher federal
funds rates
biodynamics is about increasing the
money supply
through thoughtful stimulus spending
while reaganomics would have you believe
that if you give people help it makes
them lazy
the biden idea is that if you give
people help
you make it so that they're not
constantly treading water trying to
avoid drowning
they will become more innovative they
will be more predisposed to become more
productive members of society
notice that nothing about the biden view
is remotely socialist it's almost really
just keynesianism it's a different
form of capitalism some people don't
like that
some people didn't like the fdr new deal
because they were well to the left
socialists wouldn't really have liked
the new deal because it did a lot
to sort of cement industry in american
uh the american economy
it's similar with biden there's nothing
socialist about this and as doyle
mcmanus writes in the la times piece
reagan made people hate government and
then debate
whether government should do anything at
all because the default is government is
bad
joe biden's approach is government doing
things can be popular
if they are done correctly if they are
the right things to begin with
vaccine distribution coveted stimulus
are two great starting points because
they're so popular even with many
republicans
that could then build goodwill towards
the proposals
like what joe biden outlined at last
night's speech
this is very different than what we saw
after reagan which was the demonization
of government
the constant drum beat about cut
programs cut social programs
and we could be entering a new era now i
don't say that hyperbolically it's just
you know there are errors eventually
errors change
we could be shifting to government being
seen as a tool
to help people if the tool is used
correctly even republicans we have to
admit under trump
sort of drifted away from as much
demonization of government you still saw
it of course
but they've drifted away from it a
little bit and part of it is that while
the republican party is busy fighting
this culture war
they've completely abandoned whoa sorry
i punched my mic they've completely
abandoned
policy if the options are government
doing stuff under biden
or nothing happens either way while
republicans just talk about the culture
war in dr
seuss government doing things starts to
look
quite good and that's part of why we see
a strong support among republicans
comparatively for uh joe biden on
vaccination
as well as joe biden's 1.9 trillion
dollar coveted stimulus so we are going
to follow this very closely but
the antithesis of reaganomics appears to
be
what joe biden is rolling out as
economic policy